استهداف في مخيم النصيرات في هذه اللحظات
طائرات الاحتلال الحربيه اغارت على هذا
المنزل قصفت هذا المنزل بعدد من الصواريخ
عدد من الاصابات اداد من العالقين في هذا
المنزل طواقم الانقاذ كذلك طواقم الاسعاف
وصلت في هذه اللحظات لمحاوله اطفاء هذا
الحريق وانتشال مزيدا من المصابين من هذا
المنزل
المستهدف هؤلاء الطواقم طواقم الاطفاء
الذين يفتقرون الى ادن المعدات حتى خراطيم
المياه التي نشاهدها هي ممزقه
وممزقه يعني لا
يستطيع المنقذ او حتى رجل الاطفاء
استخدامها بشكل جيد الامكانيات ضعيفه جدا
ويعني بيشتغلوا
باظافرهم بدون اي معدات او اي اغراض مخصصه
الدفاع
المدني الشهداء هنا يتم انتشالهم من هذا
المنزل شال عدد من
الشهداء هذا المنزل
المستهدف الاهالي
ي
الشهداء شال
الاعداد جديده من الشهداء
هنا
في استهداف منزل عائله حمدان يتم انتشال
اداد من الشهداء في هذه اللحظات اشلاء
وشهداء يتم
انتشالهم في هذه
[موسيقى]
اللحظ حتى اللحظه
طوا الاسعاف والانقاذ تحاول هنا شبان
يعثرون على اشلاء الشهداء في هذا
المكان
المستهدف